prenez d'eric zemmour c'est qu'ils
parlent que de lui et de la france c'est
à dire que les français entre temps il
leur parle peu et surtout dans
l'entourage politique il n'arrive pas
pour l'instant il ya aucun ralliement
qui ne soit qu il ne soit fait et je
pense que là il va à villepinte au plus
tôt père est au zénith parce qu'il se
dit qu'il va voir quinze mille 15
personnes qui vont venir ce qui est
possible mais c'est aussi un grand
risque qu'ils prennent en revanche sur
scène ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il y aura
personne à part lui il y aura oui parmi
les républicains vous aviez des gens
comme le sénateur sébastien meurant du
val d'oise très proche qui a dit non qui
s'est rallié à ciotti vous aviez aussi
guillaume pelletier qui a dit non que
ces ralliés à ciotti et horace nationale
dit à personne au fait qu'il ait rejoint
non plus vous avez à lyon quelques mario
nist mais qui avait déjà été épuré
durable nationale comme ultime
l'aumônier éloigner ce marion qui se
sont ralliés à lui mais ça reste des
prises de guerre minuscule et en
revanche on voit que beaucoup de gens
dans l'est dans les provinces et gens
qui étaient là au début de la campagne
de zemmour s'en vont écoeuré parce
qu'ils ont l'impression d'être remplacé
soit par des parisiens qui les méprise
bon soin qu'on prend pas en compte ce
qu'ils font soit qu'il est vraiment dans
une bulle enfermés qu'ils arrivent pas
le toucher qui avait déjà ce mouvement
rassemble national d'aidé des cadres
locaux qui se sentait poussé par les
parisiens qui arrive est parachuté et on
le voit avant même d'avoir un parti on a
les mêmes soucis avec l'examen et à
charny ont quand même qu'il rejoint
qu'il te faut ce temps c'est faux il l'a
charles millon vient de le démentir en
fait ce sont ces dangers nakoshi qui
fait partie de la campagne les amours
qui a dit que charles millon étaient
venus un bureau politique ce qui est
vrai que c'est le charles millon ne sais
pas du tout décidé ne sera pas là
villepin de contrairement à nous ils ont
dernièrement aujourd'hui zemmour cherche
des soutiens et les loin d'eux
des prises